paul krugman is an op-ed columnist for
the new york times next he details his
latest collection the great unraveling
losing our way in the new century this
program is an hour 15 minutes about that
on the Hitchcock book that's coming up
the eye that this is spooky the reason
we're off to a late start here is that I
missed a connection owing to a bird
strike on the plane this is this is the
second major delay I've had on this book
tour this time I actually made it I
missed on this previous one the last one
was because of tornado sweeping through
New Jersey and I've been wondering a
little bit if John Ashcroft and pat
robertson sort of i put it anyway sorry
all right okay well thank you all this
is it it's quite a time and as you know
I have this book out which is mostly my
columns it's I thought it'd be it would
be useful before i get into the book to
tell you a little bit about the
strangeness of me being in this role
writing these columns putting this book
together to just to tell you where I'm
coming from I often get questions along
the lines of what's basically what are
you doing writing this kind of stuff
what's a nice guy like you doing in a
neighborhood like this and because I am
or was still still am an academic
economist my specialty was international
economics and in particular it for much
of the past 15 years or so I've been
what you might call an ambulance chaser
somebody went around looking at at
crises in various parts of the world so
I spent a lot of time on the Mexican
crisis of 95 the Indonesian crisis of of
97 spent a lot of time get worrying
about places like Latin America and in
general looking at places that were
dysfunctional places that had
irresponsible government's
out-of-control budget deficits that had
problems of dysfunctional corporate
systems with all the stuff that doesn't
happen here all right so I was hired by
the new york times i was hired in the
summer of 99 although i didn't start
writing until january of the next year
and at a time when things were good
where we thought they were good in the
United States and we expected that I
would be writing I'd be writing negative
stories caustic stories about bad
policies abroad and sardonic stories
maybe about the the about the follies of
the new economy at home and no doubt
some critical political pieces but I
didn't think that it would be very
intense what I'd be writing about
domestic politics because the US was a
sensible reasonable place and and would
always remain so of course didn't quite
turn out that way and during the course
first of the two thousand campaign and
then increasingly since I found myself
moving on a kind of arc from puzzlement
too upset to outrage tracing what's
what's been going on in our in this
country with and and it's when you look
at these things at discovery that makes
a big difference how you feel about it
whether it's something that's happening
in in someone else's country and when
it's something that's happening your own
country so it's become a pretty stiff
it's what I guess I can say is that that
the it these are these columns are as
you as you can probably tell her no
longer written in a tone of bemused
criticism there that there's really a
lot of it's pretty upsetting and I've
ended up feeling that we really are at a
time of great crisis for the country I
started noticing that something was
seriously wrong a long time before most
of the punditocracy the commentary at
whatever your phrase is did and it was
because I started by writing about
economic policy economic policy debates
where I began to notice first during the
two thousand campaign and then even much
more so afterwards that we were seeing
something new a level of
irresponsibility level
dishonesty in in policy that we haven't
seen before and that's kind of hard to
make a case in the abstract so I thought
its I usually find it helpful to go
through a specific example now if we
talk about the things that actually got
me going that where I realized that
something something nasty was happening
there they were things that were
happening during the campaign over
Social Security privatization ordering
2001 over over the tax cut and of that
year but those are all those are all
sort of ancient outrages now so it helps
to go and and talk about something
that's more recent something that's more
on more pressure in our memories so let
me just talk for a moment about the most
recent tax cut the 2003 tax cut that was
passed that was passed through Congress
a couple of weeks after the after the
aircraft carrier landing not nice nice
reference point there okay first need to
say about it is it's wildly
irresponsible if you look at the federal
budget and you just do a just the
slightest purging of the stuff that you
know isn't true in in the budget outlook
so you you use the independent estimates
by think tanks of Washington or Goldman
Sachs or the independent projections of
actually this congressional budget
office is obliged by law to make a
projection that that pretends that
politicians are actually going to do
exactly what the law says but but it
this year it actually to its great
credit issue that kind of a well of
course that's our projection but if we
made more reasonable assumptions here's
what would be and what all of these
projections tell you is that federal
government is deep deep in the red
scarily deep in the red that we're going
to run up probably five trillion dollars
of additional debt over the next ten
years and then it will get worse because
then the baby boomers hit Social
Security and Medicare so the idea of
pushing for another long-term tax cut in
the face of that prospect it's kind of
mind-boggling do you even more
mind-boggling to think about pushing for
a tax cut at a time of war that's that's
never happened before in American
history or as far as i could find out in
anybody's
history because war is you know sort of
kind of like cost money and normally you
you almost always raise taxes in the
face of award this time we cut them so
then itself would have been kind of
disturbing but what really got me I
guess looking at this as with so many
other things is the dishonesty of the
salesmanship and that's something that
it's really hard to find president for
ever let me talk about three aspects of
that dishonesty and as well as well see
this this leads us into a general view
not just about not just about this tax
cut but about other policies economic
and beyond so first thing the budget
projections all through this initially
when the administration pushed for tax
cut this year it started with budget
projections that said that we'd be back
in budget surplus by 2008 then now it
says we'll be back to a deficit of only
250 billion by 2008 but but all of these
projections are they're just silly
everyone knows they're silly they're
based upon a whole set of things that
you know are not going to happen like
the investment tax credit of 2002 will
be allowed to expire we know that's not
going to happen in fact the
administration doesn't want it to happen
we know it's based on the assumption
that the alternative minimum tax Bellino
the oldest technical stuff you don't
want to know about but but the point is
that not only that there are things that
everyone knows are not going to happen
but they're things that the
administration is actively pushing to to
stop like expiration of this of the
investment tax credit failure to extend
the alternative minimum tax thing and so
on so in effect the administration is
now saying don't worry the deficit will
be cut in half if Congress doesn't give
us what we want which is kind of a
peculiar way to make a budget so that
realistically the budget is much worse
it's it's scarily bad and and i'll talk
about just how bad it is a little later
in this talk second thing is the cost of
the tax package which did the revenue
loss it there were some moderate members
of Congress who had a brief burst of
responsibility didn't last long but
anyway they they had a sudden urge
to to try to do something so they said
the 10-year cost must not exceed 350
billion dollars and so the
administration went and said fine we're
not going to change the tax cuts at all
what we're going to do is write the law
so that they sunset at just about every
provision in the bill goes away sometime
between now and two thousand eight those
sunsets are not net they are not
intended to happen nobody expects to
actually have a Klein in to have the
taxes go back up to the previous levels
in fact the administration you know the
day the bill was signed started lobbying
to make it all permanent the use of
sunsets it's just one of those things
you do to you know produce artificially
low numbers and it has been a favorite
tool of this administration the best
example of that was actually the 2001
tax cut which also was under a cap
imposed by a slight fit of
responsibility on the part of Congress
so they made the whole thing sunset in
in the year 2011 so that well there are
a number of things about that that are
funny but the best one is the estate tax
under current law as written the estate
tax phases out and is completely gone by
2010 and then in 2011 returns to his
2000 schedule which means that if you
have an extremely wealthy aunt and she
goes in December 2010 you inherit the
estate tax free but if she makes it to
January 2011 everything above six
hundred thousand dollars pays a fifty
five percent tax rate I suggested at the
time that the bill be called the throw
mama from the Train Act of 2001
the point being of course that is just
funny it's not it's not intended to
happen the last piece again this did
back to this year's tax cut the last
piece is who gets the benefits now the
line first in the state of the union
then repeated many times both by Bush
and by government officials is 92
million people will receive an average
tax cut of a thousand dollars this year
now that's not exactly it's it's not a
lie it's literally true but it's meant
you're meant to hear it as saying that
the typical family is going to get a
thousand dollars and the trick here of
course is that the the speech writer is
hope and we're vindicated in that hope
that most people including most people
in the press don't understand what the
word average means so let me explain if
if Bill Gates walks into a bar the
average net worth of the patrons arises
by a couple of billion dollars okay
right the you get the point if you
actually looked at the at the 2003 tax
cut is true it's about a 90 billion a 90
billion dollar tax cut for for two
thousand three of the hundred and thirty
million taxpayers in the country 40
million get nothing the 90 million
remaining if you divide the total tax
cut by the number of taxpayers it's
about a thousand each but of course that
is largely primarily consists of very
large tax cuts for a few people at the
top of the distribution and not much for
anyone else so that about half of the
population this year got either no tax
cut or less than a hundred dollars the
typical tax cut might say was a hundred
dollars so again it's deliberately
deceptive rhetoric it was intended to
intended to make something that was like
everything this administration has done
heavily tilted towards the very well-off
seemed as if it were a middle-class a
middle-class thing okay now if it was
just this tax cut it was just this one
bill then this would be stuffed to be
angry about to be annoyed about but it
wouldn't be a big really big issue the
problem is of course that it's been like
this on everything the the selling of
the
the content on the selling of the 2003
tax cut the sort of combination of
irresponsibility of bait and switch
telling you one thing and then telling
you something else later on oh by the
way there's this 87 billion we forgot to
mention I didn't mention that I'm sorry
what happens when your plane has been
hit by a bird one of the things about
those budget projections I forgot to
mention is that the amount of money
allowed in those budget projections for
post-war post-war occupation and
pacification costs which was zero and
when asked well why didn't we have some
number and therefore that administration
officials would say well we don't know
how much it's going to cost so if you
have this is the way you budget for your
family right if you have a large future
expense but you don't know how big it's
going to be you assume for family
planning purposes that will be zero all
right this is uh all right okay well
this is okay first tax cut was the same
set of principles the 2001 tax cut was
done the same way phony irresponsible
phony phony projections etc etc but the
the whole style applies to many other
areas of policy from well environmental
policy is certainly one we're where the
combination of irresponsibility and
deception is is very striking together
with much more so than on economic
policy the Orwellian use of language so
the healthy forests initiative is indeed
a plan to allow lot of timber companies
to cut down a bunch of trees and the
clear skies although the little cupcake
but but the first step towards the clear
skies is the biggest weakening of the
Clean Air Act since since its inception
and so on so there's this there's all of
that and not what I ever expected to be
writing about foreign policy now
whatever you think of the case for for
war in Iraq the striking thing is that
first of all the planning was
irresponsible and this is the military
the military professionals all said we
don't know how we're going to keep this
going to tie up a large number of our
soldiers for an unknown perry
of time this we don't actually have the
resources for that kind of thing that's
not what our army is designed for and
the administration said well we're you
know plan a is we'll we'll move in and
install our favorite exiles and and
we'll be out in six months and it'll all
be fine and there was no plan B and the
the army chief of staff was fired for
forewarning that that what would hit
that that what might he was put what
yeah this is what happens when again
when a bird hits your plane he was he
was fired for warning that what what in
fact did happen might happen that that
there would be an extended extended
deployment and it would really run down
the soldier so just just on sheer
practicality grounds the my my
understanding now is that the wear and
tear on the military is sort of the
military the National Defense equivalent
of the deficit it's it's a it's a very
severe drain based upon a highly
irresponsible policy and of course the
deceptive sales campaign and I think we
all know about that then the it was just
clear that they were hyping the threat
because this was something they wanted
to do and ever shifting rationale the
the original tax cut first was about
returning a surplus then when the
surplus went away it was about creating
jobs then what turned out it wasn't
creating jobs it was about long-run
growth or something the the war was
about links with 911 well there weren't
aliens with 911 was about nuclear
weapons program what wasn't it's about
it's about democracy that's what's about
so it's the it's the whole style of
things that are changing now some of my
even some by liberal friends telling me
that I'm overreacting you know that I'm
I'm a political naive here that I should
have known you know all governments lie
all administration's allow political
considerations to dictate policy all
governments give special interests more
more weight than they should but this is
that this is another level I think this
the point is there's a difference in
degree that's so great as to be a
difference in kind so that yes all
governments
but that what the the up is down ism
I've seen that phrase several times
recently of this administration is
something unique to take a a plan that
is that diverts away a large part of the
resources that support social security
and call it a plan to save Social
Security that's that's something I've
never seen before that's that's two
minus one equals four Clinton might have
said that two plus one equals three
point two Bush says two minus one equals
four so it's a very different different
style of dishonesty politicization yes
of course decisions are political but
it's very difficult to find anything in
this administration that isn't political
it's very hard to find any examples of
of a policy that is actually designed to
solve a problem we're actually up the
administration responding to a problem
by trying to solve it as opposed to
trying to use it to promote a
pre-existing agenda so whatever happens
to the economy long-term tax cuts for
high high and for high-income people are
the response whatever happens to us in
international affairs pursuing the same
foreign policy objectives that dick
cheney tried to install as the national
security doctrine back in 1992 is the
response and so there's this this sort
of you know tunnel vision whatever it is
they they just proceed with what they
wanted to do anyway and there's no sense
that they're actually trying to govern
in in any sense that I understand
special interests yes I mean we used to
bemoan how much political capital the
Clinton administration was spending on
behalf of Chiquita banana and trade
negotiations all right stuff did happen
that's different from the sheer erase or
a ratio of any distinctions between the
lobbyists the industries and the
government officials that's taken place
right now there was a story I don't know
how well it was covered I was in a
different place reading it in the
newspapers but there's there was just a
major change in mining policy announced
on Friday afternoon as things that they
hope you won't notice always are which
involved disposing of waste from
online mining operations the law says
that for each 20-acre claim that you get
to use 5 acres additional acres of
public land to dump waste on the rule
has now been revised which is well yes
you each each parcel is 5 acres but in
fact they will now give mining companies
as much public land for waste disposal
as they want unlimited now there's
possibly an economic argument for this
though I think you can pretty are
strongly argue that it's outweighed by
the environmental impacts which are very
large but the main thing to notice is
that the Secretary of the Interior is a
long time basically built her career
working for the mining industry the
Deputy Secretary of the Interior built
his career working for the mining
industry and is still in fact receiving
receiving paychecks from from mining
interests the the undersecretary under
him is built her career working for the
mining industry and so on right down the
line there's a level of rawness about
the interpenetration personal financial
of special interests and politicians
that that's that's pretty pretty amazing
I guess I i I've descended to the level
where I actually I'm going to quote
David Letterman who who said that we
really do need to finance Iraqi
construction and in in making out that
check remember that there are 2 l's in
haliburton so um give you a sense of how
bad i think it is i'm going to give you
a startling admission I miss Ronald
Reagan yeah the reason the reason i miss
Ronald Reagan actually the two reasons i
miss Reagan one is that although the
policies in some respects looked similar
deal with the ozone layer by wearing
hats and so on tax cuts for the rich
there was a certain level of innocence
about it Reagan did cut tax cuts did cut
taxes for rich people and he did say
that
you know eats in it was it was certainly
a step in the direction that we've now
further followed but he didn't say he
had a theory he said if you cut taxes
for rich people a rising tide will raise
all boats supply-side economics you
could say that you didn't believe the
theory with which which I did and others
you know like me did but the point was
that the that if you believe the theory
then then the rest followed he didn't go
around saying that tax cut for rich
people that's not tax for rich people
thanks cut for rich people that's a tax
cut for the middle class and lower
income workers didn't didn't just
misrepresent didn't just lie about what
the policy was which of course is what
this administration does all the time
the other thing is that Reagan to some
extent at least responded to events so
when it became clear after a year that
the rosy scenarios under which the tax
cut would pay for itself were untrue he
did actually accept the substantial
rollback so there was the big reagan tax
cut of 81 but the big raise reagan tax
increase of 82 which by no means brought
rates back to where they were but was in
fact a i think as a you know by its
relative to the economy actually reagan
presided over the biggest tax increase
in the US history which was the 82
rollback never find that here that this
at this point the deficit picture is
much grimmer than it was when Reagan was
there don't don't believe these attempts
to say it's it's no worse there are both
technical reasons why it's not not why
it's why it's worse and also there's the
fact that the baby boomers are 20 years
older so the big burden of paying for
Social Security and Medicare is much
closer now than it was then and yet
there's been actually they're still put
there pushing for additional tax cuts
now so there there's been no
responsiveness um ok so I'm this Ronald
Reagan I also i also miss this Richard
Nixon now that's I don't really remember
Nixon very much but a couple of things
that to say one is of course the behind
a friendlier face all of that style of
politics is back
and John Dean the Watergate theme
recently remarked that even Nixon didn't
go after the wives so it's a right it's
it really is pretty serious the other
thing is Nixon actually did believe in
governing the country didn't think
anyone else you'd have a shot at it but
but if you talk to people at the
agencies like the EPA who are old timers
who've been around for a long time they
actually talk about the Nixon years as a
golden age because he was serious you
know having having signed the Clean Air
Act he said well let's let's go out and
see how we can make this thing work and
enforce it having having decided that he
was going to do an economic policy made
some mistakes but but he was serious
about actually trying to run the economy
as opposed to trying to ram through an
agenda so now we don't have any of that
so the question then is what do we have
and this is in the book I have the main
new piece as an extended introduction
trying to talk about what I think is
actually going on and I think the only
way to make sense of what's happening
right now is to say that we do not just
have a Conservative administration in
power that that is that has policies I
disagree with what we actually face is a
quite radical challenge to the system
that the people in power are either are
themselves or defer to the views of
people who really want to rip up the
system we've had for the last three
generations or so and replace it with
something quite different now I dug its
of course the immediate am I saying that
there's some hidden conspiracy the
answer is no I'm saying there's an open
conspiracy it's actually right out there
to look at so on the area I know best
which is tax tax policy economic policy
just go to the Heritage Foundation which
is the intellectual headquarters for all
this stuff which is actually where where
Dick Cheney went went last week to give
his his speech and read their materials
and you'll discover that they they use
the terms new deal and great society as
terms of abuse that is that they regard
everything that's happened since
Franklin Roosevelt
the Social Security Medicare Medicaid as
illegitimate government shouldn't be
doing that government should be
minimalist as it was before and so
they've made it quite clear that their
ultimate objective is to push us back to
get get rid of the social insurance
state as we as we know it today if you
listen to Grover Norquist the the
lobbyist who's at the core of and this
is you know this is not a just some guy
this is the a guy who meets weekly with
the leaders of the Senate in the house
to vet staff appointments all right so
that's how central he is he also happens
to be colorful in his language which is
useful because it he's a little franker
than most and he said I don't I don't
want to eliminate the government I just
want to shrink it down to the size where
I can drown it in the bathtub and you
ask then ask these people how they want
to do all this how they want to shrink
down the government to something much
smaller and they they they say well we
can't if you just ask people do you want
your benefits cut they won't do it but
what we can do is we can starve the
beast as the favorite phrase starve the
Beast deprived government of the revenue
it needs to provide these social
insurance programs you can't go to
people and say oh let's let's eliminate
Medicare but you can create a series of
budget deficits so you say we must we
have to curb these expenses and you can
gradually shrink the thing down deprive
it of its lifeblood to quote Norquist
again so that's a pretty that's pretty
radical view same thing different
different subject just church-state
relations now if you if you go and look
at what John Ashcroft or representative
Tom DeLay have to say it's very clear
that they really want a major injection
of Christian fundamentalism into into
the way our government is run take a
look at to take a look at foreign policy
and it's it's not it's not talking about
some obscure conspiracy to point out
that that essentially Cheney's Cheney's
guys from 1992 have been wanting a
doctrine
preventive war and starting with Iraq
for that for more than a decade and that
this this was their their goalie a
really radical shift in the nature of
the system and it's worth saying i guess
the latest thing the latest diatribe
against people like myself say oh you're
just know you so full of hate you use
such harsh language it's worth just
saying that there that catch these
people in unguarded moments and they'll
say pretty remarkable things the if
anyone caught grover norquist on fresh
air with Terry Gross she came around to
the issue of the estate tax which is of
all the pieces of this tax cut that
we've had they plan to eliminate the
estate tax is the most amazing because
the estate tax falls only on a small
number of very wealthy people the bulk
of it comes from really just a few
thousand two states a year and to
completely eliminate it seems to be what
what's that about what why would we want
to do that when when were desperately
short of revenue for all kinds of other
purposes Terry Gross asked Norquist
whether it it wasn't it true that the
estate tax only falls on a small
fraction of the population and his
response was well no Hitler only killed
a small fraction of the population think
about the language all right i am going
to even though i'm on camera i'm going
to take off my jacket and sound of a
smashing cell phone sorry guys okay so
why don't you hear more about this if
what i'm saying if it's so relatively
obvious if both the irresponsibility and
dishonesty of the policies and the clear
sense of ulterior motives is clear-cut
why don't you hear more about it i just
i just realized this again let me just
backtrack a bit this is the least
coherent of course the one of the time
i'm actually on camera I'm the least
coherent but let me just say the
question that people should ask which is
but am I saying that Bush is this kind
of radical am I saying that Bush wants
to roll back Social Security and that
here that he wants a militarized foreign
policy and all of that to which the
answer is I have no idea what Bush
thinks were understands or knows here
not by the way not that he's stupid I
don't I think that's a big big mistake
that people make it's not it's not about
stupidity he's not intellectual but that
is not alas I hate to say this in a
bookstore but that is not the same thing
but the point is that Bush and his inner
circle have decided that their that that
basically have decided the daddy lost
the last election because he didn't have
the firm support of the hard right and
their political strategy is to make
moderate noises but in all essential
things to give the hard right what it
wants and so the the the the radicals
are dictating policy and it doesn't
really matter whether Bush himself
actually shares the goals or even thinks
about what the country will look like in
10 years the radicals are dictating
policy okay so why don't you hear more
about this why why is this more you know
well I wasn't entirely alone but it's
true I was the only person with that
prominent two piece of real journalistic
real estate on loan to talk about this
stuff a couple of things one is the it's
just too steep a hill to climb it's hard
to believe just just hard to face up to
the thought that something that drastic
may be happening in this country is just
very hard I an experience about a year
ago I talked I wrote a piece about Tom
DeLay and I quoted some of his stuff he
has said that he's in office to promote
a biblical worldview that and that he
pursued Bill Clinton not because of
policy differences but because he felt
that Bill Clinton didn't share that
biblical worldview and what does he mean
by a biblical worldview it turns out
well after the Columbine school
shootings he called a press conference
representative Tom DeLay called a press
conference to its to explain that the
reason that things like this happen is
because we teach evolution in the high
schools now I gone I got a bunch of mail
and phone calls from liberal friends
that saying that I had a problem that i
was going off off my rocker what does it
matter they said what some crazy guy in
Congress says this is representative Tom
DeLay indeed he has a crazy guy he's
also the house majority leader and and
given the way things actually work right
now it the Speaker of the House is a
figurehead so Tom DeLay runs Congress
this is the second most powerful man in
America and that the point is that but
people don't want to believe that things
have reached that extreme appoint other
things to say role of the media yes of
course i am the media but I'm a very
eccentric and accidental part of the
media and I I don't know quite what the
times thinks of what I'm doing I mean I
think they're they're very careful not
to not to dictate too much but but I do
sell papers but I wonder what they I
wonder you know if they it they didn't
know what they were getting out I didn't
know what I was getting into the point
is anyway about the media a good part of
the media is part of the machine part of
the vast right-wing conspiracy if you
like it's certainly a The Washington
Times or The Mirage Empire Fox News we
do really live in Orwellian times right
if you were ready a novelty you would
never have dared to say the slogan of of
the propaganda arm would be fair and
balanced I i I'm almost losing hope by
the way I do insult Fox News at every
opportunity and the desperate hope that
they would will sue me but I've lost I
seem to have lost out anyway okay so
that's one large piece then there's the
mainstream media although foxit by
viewership is more mainstream than CNN
now but anyway but anyway the rest of
the media what the media suffer from
first of all is a very severe almost
pathological case of even-handedness
that is they ought to be objective
that's what we ought to be doing but
objective is hard and objective can also
make you a lot of enemies so usually
settle for being even-handed which is
not the same thing
oh that whatever whatever anybody says
you carefully quote some Republicans and
some Democrats giving them exactly the
same number of column lines and then
you've written a balanced piece I
summarized this at one point in a column
which led led people to several people
thought I was talking about them the I
said that if if if Bush said that the
earth was flat the headlines in major
mainstream publications would be shape
of the earth views differ and that's
about the way it is you can you can read
several stories like that in major
newspapers including major newspapers
based in New York in the last in the
last week or so okay the one more thing
there is intimidation now at this point
it's the intimidation isn't isn't of the
form we're going to we're going to come
and beat you up or with the the Homeland
Security Administration is going to send
you to a Cajun Gitmo that's not it's not
it's not there or maybe I should say not
not there yet but anyway what it is is
nonetheless it's pretty it's pretty
severe a news organization that crosses
the ruling coalition is going to be of
course subjected to howls about liberal
bias it's going to receive mass mailing
campaigns organized whether by various
think tanks or groups or or by Rush
Limbaugh it's going to generally find
itself under harassment an individual
journalists who crosses them is going to
find himself under the same thing plus I
mean first you do get amazing hate mail
and I should have a pair of tongs to
pick the stuff up but you you also get
efforts to to drum up scandals the all
the stuff that they managed to turn a
small money-losing investment into a 70
million dollar seven-year investigation
is now turned not at the people in power
but at those who criticize the people in
power it's it's amazing and it's it's
pretty it can be pretty upsetting if you
want if you want to take these people on
you better have a
a very boring private life it's to give
you a sense of the kind of level of
intimidation that is now we've become
accustomed to it already but there was
this nice those of you saw my call my
friday i mentioned it but the few weeks
ago Christiane Amanpour the CNN
correspondent gave an interview in which
he expressed some regret about her
networks failure to to present a more
balanced view before the war and she
said something like to to a certain
degree perhaps I and and even my station
were intimidated by the administration
then and it's [ __ ] its foot soldiers
of Fox News a little fairly forthright
statement good for her Fox News issued a
statement saying it's better to be
viewed as a foot soldier for Bush than
as a spokeswoman for al-qaeda that's
that's the kind of level of things and
and people now how many journalists are
thinking in cells I better not cross
these guys I don't think it quite works
that directly I think it's that every
time you do cross them you get an
electric shock and you get kind of
conditioned not not to cross them okay
um how bad is it well I think it's it's
pretty severe and the thing that i can
again that i can measure most i'm not
sure it it's not it's fighting the the
things that I know best given what I
know are not necessarily the things that
bother me most as a citizen so if you
ask what's really scares me it would be
civil liberties issues and ultimately
environmental issues but in terms of
economics are bad enough as is we've got
thanks to these policies sold on false
pretenses we've got budget trade debt
numbers that are quickly looking like
like those of a banana republic I this
is going back to the beginning what I
know I know banana republics ok I know
crises and I do know that that if I saw
a third world country with the budget
deficit as big as ours and with the
obvious unwillingness to to to make any
realistic adjustments obvious
unwillingness to collect taxes
or since the programs that taxes are
supposed to be financing are popular to
cut those programs by the amounts that
would be necessary I would be warning
I'd be saying this country is seriously
in the danger zone it's kind of
interesting i just learned that I people
say oh well you're just chicken little
turns out that Lehman Brothers has
developed a a crisis warning system
that's based on a bunch of economic
indicators it's it's called Damocles and
it they claim that of course
retrospectively it would have it would
have told you about the asian financial
crisis on the argentine crisis they
would have caught the big crises and the
good news from Damocles is that all of
the developing countries that that have
had big crises in the past now appear to
be well out of the danger zone they're
all getting rather low readings on
Damocles the bad news is that the u.s.
if you applied Emma Cleese to the US it
says you know that alarm bells start
ringing now so that that will happen we
we are we're it won't happen for a while
because the world the world financial
market can't believe like like like like
the pundits and the populace can't
believe this is happening to America but
at a certain point there will be a
realization that we really are we really
have lost it lost our way and maybe lost
our heads in the new century it doesn't
have to be like this I guess then just
to to wind this down the the country is
rich has enormous resources we taxes are
by our own standards or by those of
other advanced countries are rather low
the particularly at the upper end of the
income distribution by the time the bush
tax cuts are fully filtered through tax
cuts on on the the truly wealthy will be
tax tax rates on the truly wealthy will
be down to levels not seen since the
1920s we also have income inequality
that is right back at 1920s levels by
the way and so we have a the point is
that it's not hard to imagine raising
the money to you know we have these huge
budget deficits but if we went halfway
to a Canadian level of Taxation we'd
have a budget surplus so it's we have
the resources to deal with these things
think we also actually have the public
the public's fundamental values are not
are not nearly as radical as those that
are that are being imposed on the nation
that when you ask people which is more
important tax cuts or preserving social
security yet overwhelming response of
Social Security when you ask people
political religious questions the
country still appears to be quite
tolerant quite open-minded the problem
is that people don't know that this
radical agenda is being imposed they
don't understand what's happening it's
very hard for them to understand what's
happening because it it comes so
thoroughly wrapped in the flag and what
that says that the most important thing
is to try to get the word out which is
something of course that I'm trying to
do that an increasing number of people
are trying to do and I'm hoping that I
can I and the other the other good
liberal books of this fall my publisher
hates this but I have to say they
there's a whole raft of really good ones
Molly Ivins joke on us and David corn
just out and much as it hurts me to say
it Al Franken is are really really add
and and week I you know what we hope but
my host said we hope we can get the word
out and at least i think if we can
actually have the discussion if we can
actually get what's happening out into
the open then the good guys win when the
argument so that's what we're trying to
do and thank
ok
you
lacking instructors from my host i'm
just going to call on people and and
i'll repeat questions or abbreviated
version soap because there's a camera
there yes could you comment the treasury
report that was excerpted from the 2004
budget in which they projected a 44
trillion-dollar uncounted liability for
Social Security and Medicare I'd like to
know about the accuracy and why it was
taken out and why the media didn't cover
it oh boy okay question is that there
was a treasury report saying that the
unfunded liabilities of Social Security
and Medicare are much bigger even than
we've been saying and the why was it
taken out why wasn't covered more by the
media there's actually I have a it's not
as simple as stories you might imagine
you might think that this was a this was
something that would have helped to
discredit the administration but the
actual reason why the stuff was in there
was an attempt to discredit Social
Security and Medicare it was actually
going the other way and the reason that
was done that the the difference was
most the standard estimates now of the
budget shortfall for Social Security
Medicare run out to the year 2075 and
this study said well suppose we go we go
on forever now there's there are a
couple of points there one is it now I
the reason I'm falling silent is is that
there's a real danger of me turning back
into a college professor and starting to
have too much stuff here I i think i
think that that was that's actually not
helpful that now the uncertainties of
the out years beyond 20 75 or so large
that you want to discount at somewhat
now given what i was saying about
occupation costs of course if you have a
large unknown expense sometime in the
future you don't want to assume at 0 but
it's probably a good idea not to think
too hard now about how you're going to
deal with expenses that are
still 75 years away the the other thing
about it is that a lot of that is driven
by medical costs and it's not entirely
clear why future why current generations
should be taxing themselves to pay
higher medical costs for two or three
generations down the line which will be
driven largely by the availability of
medical procedures that we haven't yet
invented so I think that was actually
kind of that was kind of a bum steer
that was the wrong now the interesting
point of course is that if you use the
standard 75-year calculation what they
will always tell you is what the the
standard line now is but well our big
problem are these huge looming Social
Security Medicare deficits which is
intended to make you think that we
cannot sustain those systems but the
interesting point right now is that the
on the 75 year basis the the shortfall
from Medicare and Social Security is
actually smaller than the shortfall
resulting from the bush tax cuts so that
the truth is if we have a looming fiscal
problem it is is as much or more due to
the tax cuts of the last three years
than Social Security and Medicare and
part of what was going on with this
study was to move the goalposts oh that
would no longer be true yeah all right
Arnold was the question um yeah I I
actually had it had a day of despair
after that and not because I know that
he's going to be a bad governor I mean I
don't know what he's going to do as
governor but that is the point all right
um this he ran with no no coherent
campaign nothing at all just I'm going
to rescind the increase in vehicle
license fees and I'm not going to touch
education and I'm going to balance the
budget and I guess he's got he's going
to you know the people at a digital
light industrial light and magic I guess
they're going to fabricate some money to
do that right it's a it's it's not a it
made no sense at all so that was it was
disturbing that people would vote on
that basis it was disturbing
California's problems are
they're the driest most straightforward
stuff it's just rina shade stuff there's
a okay coms went bust California's
income tax revenues are down so you have
to have some combination of spending
cuts and tax increases there's nothing
magical about it and there's nothing
mysterious about and there's nothing
magical about the solution and it is
very depressing that people would vote
for someone believing that he can solve
these problems without explaining the
choices because he's a tough guy it's
even more depressing when he isn't in
fact the tough guy he just plays one in
movies and the most disturbing thing was
the media the media coverage was just
you kept on waiting for them to decide
okay but this isn't Entertainment
Tonight this is about state finances and
they never did and sheer falsehoods got
repeated over and over again you kept on
hearing about the the 38 billion dollar
California budget deficit the real
numbers eight you kept on hearing about
the terrible state of the California
economy which is actually done slightly
better than the national average these
past two years just it so that that just
was a reminder of how hard it's going to
be to get any sense into this into the
next election yeah
tax free and yet you're going to
California there is a tax worries no
taxes it seems that really since the
Reagan administration we've raised the
generation now to think yeah taxes as
hard work okay the question for those
who couldn't hear is how do we get past
this notion that taxes are bad and we
must freeze or lower taxes and it's
going to be hard mean that it I've to
admit my optimism which which wells up
every once in a while has to deal with a
couple of really bad things that
happened Alabama was a terrifying
example that was a actually was a tax
cut for lower-income people a couple
with a tax increase for higher-income
people and the right ran a campaign
hiring people with rural black accents
to to say your taxes are going to go up
and it worked and the referendum was
defeated overwhelmingly yeah we're going
to if I let me say I think politically
it is not going to be just enough for
somebody with sensible ideas to to win
the 2004 presidential election by by ten
electoral votes because just just
imagine me that worse things could
happen clearly we could continue
unabated down the path we're going but
just try to imagine what it's going to
take to to get this country back on
track all of it technically easy all of
it politically very hard and then try to
imagine the net the the next
presidential term with well take your
pick but Howard Dean in the White House
and Tom DeLay still running Congress
it's going to be the French I think you
talk about cohabitation and that talk
about that cohabitation wow so it's
going to be very difficult we people
have not got to get people to understand
the link between taxes and and the
things the taxes pay for and right now
we've massively that you know the
distance people just imagine that that
that public services grow on trees
you're trying okay yeah oh yes yeah go
ahead
years
once again that down the line in the
next lab danger
wait everyone out
yeah a question is that there's the
theory that that roughly every 70 years
which is about right in this case that
we have a train wreck and that once you
get out of the other end 20 years later
you come up with a better social system
so i guess civil war franklin roosevelt
and now now this i think new zealand
might be a nice place to be while while
we get through those 20 years it's and
the trouble is of course we right it's
funny actually what one thing that
always occurs to me is we could use we
could use a franklin roosevelt right now
and if you can find one let me know it's
it the trouble is of course it when yeah
I think we're headed for a period of
turmoil I think we're headed for
obviously next year is going to be the
meanest bitterest ugliest presidential
campaign since since the 1920s and and
probably what follows will be worse and
it's but it's pure faith that what comes
out at the end is something better I
mean you want to believe in the genius
of America and manifest destiny and I
hope that's right but I do worry that of
course what could come out at the end
would be would be that sort of
confirmation that we that we we kind of
really blew it so yes but it's point it
doesn't matter right the point is the
point is to try to try to make it come
out the right way way at the back sorry
I'll get you later
okay rebound in the stock market is it
is it solid will turn around will crash
what does it say don't know the thing
about about stock prices is that they
bear a very loose relationship to any
fundamentals the the old line used to be
that the stock market had predicted 9 of
the last five recessions and I don't
know what I don't know quite what to
make of of this one the only need to say
is that there does appear to be quite a
lot of I don't think we've gotten the
bubbles out of our system I think
there's quite a lot of naive buying
going on right now and for what it's
worth insider selling is proceeding
briskly even as the market rises so this
is I find it i still think stocks look
look very pricey and and the economy is
the economy itself just to say the about
ya know we clearly had brisk growth in
the third quarter but not in jobs and
which way is it going to go from here
and the answer is nobody knows and if
anyone says he knows that only proves
his ignorance it's a it's the numbers
are weird right now very they're just
they're different indicators pointing in
different directions and so I have no
idea where we're going from here I did
try to call you earlier yeah sorry
I didn't read it but I can imagine okay
okay let me just try and remind myself
talk not to forget the second half the
question I didn't read this thing on
instapundit I heard about it um mean it
sounds it sounded ology and yeah I'm
making the economic arguments pretty
clearly and then I'm also saying since
the economic arguments of the other side
seemed so obviously wrong and and since
there's so much obvious dishonesty going
on then as a citizen I start trying to
understand their motives and the story
that that's it and the the point i think
is is if certainly I've been right so
far in in being pessimistic about the
budget and and also in concluding quite
early on that we were not going to get a
reasonable response when the budget went
into deficit so what more to say it but
it is funny it for those who haven't
read this just it's just saying Oh
rather than actually try to respond to
to what I'm saying it's well but Krugman
talks about the motives of people and he
shouldn't do that economists should be
pure and and only discussed the theory
one more thing i think i should say that
look a lot of the economists advocating
the the policies of this administration
are economists well there's no licensing
requirement but if you ask now that can
that can sound that can sound and it
probably is pretentious and and snippy
but the point being that it there are
conservative economists who you know
have like really done work
and and earned their reputation but a
lot of the people you see on TV a lot of
the people you read about even in the
New York Times Magazine have careers
that entirely consist of working for
right-wing think tanks or right-wing
politicians that's just that's just not
the real thing for what it's worth sorry
I'm I'm riffing here if I think I still
freaked out by that bird on the the the
Forth Worth the Robert Barrow on Harvard
rights for Business Week is supportive
of the administration's policies what's
interesting is that what he says to
explain why he supports it is exactly
what I'm saying is the ulterior motive
he says well we need to starve the Beast
budget deficits are good to starve the
Beast so he said he's a smarty cause he
does in fact know his stuff and that's
why he's basically saying there's a con
going on here and I approve of it fair
enough I mean but that's but that's what
I'm saying that you have to ask what the
motive is it when when Stephen Moore
says no we're gonna have these wonderful
supply side effects and it'll all pay
for itself well two things first I
that's just not plausible and then
secondly who is stephen moore sorry how
did he get there and the answer is
entirely as a political servant
democrats first i actually haven't done
the homework to go through as soon as i
get to spend a few days a few nights
sleeping in my own bed and and a few
days at home i'm actually planning to do
a workup to just go through what i think
so i can't actually i can't actually say
i mean all of them are what was
Bismarck's remark about about a bavarian
being halfway between an austrian and a
man the i think all of the Democratic
platforms are sort of halfway between
the Bush administration and actually
making sense which is which you know
it's a big improvement so but I I can't
I can't say that the the other question
I guess is going to just do I endorse
when I can't of course the times rules I
can't do that in fact times rules I
don't endorse you know at all so in
principle you don't know which party on
supporting in the for election or and
you don't know which party William
Safire is endorsing either
the bucket not you know you can tell my
my instinctive preference just being the
kind of person I am and also just seeing
what I think is going on is that it's
got to be somebody who's combative
somebody's not going to try to be polite
somebody's going to come out really
swinging and and that it that can't be
somebody who's whose campaign plan is to
promise is to be like Bush only less so
and that of course kind of narrows the
field we try okay there okay yes
question is investment houses New York
Bangz people who should be thinking long
term irrational and often aren't a very
important point to make there actually
is one of the first essays in doing the
old stories in the book in it articles
in my book is as a piece i wrote for
fortune back in i think 97 called seven
Habits of Highly defective investors
which which was I actually kind of I
think eliminated a lot of future
consulting business by writing I didn't
say I didn't say which meeting I was at
but but they knew and it was it was a
meeting of oven of the investment
professionals that I I came away with
some kind of caustic thoughts about it I
think the biggest thing to say is look
these people are there are there
careerists and if you're working
managing money for a mutual fund or for
an investment bank while they're there
so there's an asymmetry in the risks if
you take a position that is very
different from what everyone else is
saying and and you're right well that's
very nice but if you take a position
that is very different from what
everyone else is saying and you're wrong
that's the end of your career whereas if
you take a position which is the same as
what everyone else is saying and you're
all wrong together you don't suffer at
all so there's a real incentive to too
there's actually a paper by
by losing I think it I think it's jeremy
stein but i'm not sure but there was
actually a paper heard on the street h
ard that was was talking about actually
tried to model all of this stuff the
point is that that there really is that
when you have agents managing your money
they do tend to exhibit they do tend to
run in a herd so it's very hard now
they're still as the question and that
the big question right now is if you
look at the budget picture look at the
the real severity of it why are why are
people still willing to lend the federal
government money for ten years at ten
percent sorry for ten years at four
percent even if you think it's only a
one chance in five or one chance in ten
that we're going to have a very serious
crack up that should be giving you a
much larger risk premium to which the
only answer is but it always seems to be
that way that right up until the moment
of crisis there's always a people want
to believe and particularly advanced
countries tend to get benefit of the
doubt you do you think yourself well it
can happen to a country like that so I
think what I I do think the United
States at some point which of course we
probably have some years to run when
when people will just assume that
somehow it's all going to work out but
we are at a certain point going to have
a wily coyote moment for scholars who
know road runner wile e coyote would
always run off the edge of a cliff a
little ways and then notice there was
nothing under him and then so that's I
think what's going to happen to the bond
mark in the US yeah
okay questions about the environment and
the privatization of natural resources
particularly water ah wow I haven't done
the I I have a bunch of things people
sent me about water privatization and I
haven't done the homework so i can't i
can't speak out on that yeah well the
air look what we're seeing now is a
remarkable rollback of environmental
regulations the one that that really
we've had a couple of stories from page
then it fades out again the story about
new source review is really in some ways
just encapsulates what's going on here
right we have the Clean Air Act Clean
Air Act through a mistake basically of
the original policy grandfather's
existing facilities so you have rules
that apply to new new facilities new
power plants but not too old ones and
became clear over time that the trouble
was that you would you know bit by bit
replace all of the parts of an existing
facility but call it and with so it in
effect become a new one but but you
would be the it would still be the same
old facility under the law and so the
when people put the clear and clean air
act into effect they expected much more
sustained much more rapid they expected
that all old power plants would be gone
by now and and of course they aren't so
we've had this thing enforced with
increasing aggressiveness during the
Clinton administration of new source
review which was it that the EPA would
take a look at a new at an investment in
a in an existing industrial or power
plant and say well look this in effect
is a new source of pollution and
therefore has to obey the the rules it
that that's not grandfathered anymore
and that's just been eliminated by the
administration the thing about it is it
severely guts the act and it happens to
be worth something between five and ten
billion dollars to a small group of
companies who guess what gave a lot of
money for the campaign and also have
employed quite a few various points
quite a few people who are now in the
administration so we're talking about
this the ability of the government to
hand over very large favors to
in this case in viral axing
environmental rules on and in effect to
profit both politically and personally
from it and the absence of any effective
watchdogging God sorry in English any
now can be verb but anyway and did the
absence of effective watchdogging in our
current environment it makes it makes it
all possible there's much more of that
and the water privatization I really
know I'm supposed to my colleague Tom
Friedman says it's a target-rich
environment and there's just more stuff
than you can go after okay i'm gonna
tell you about two more i think and then
i got signed some books yeah okay
questions about foreign policy bush
sharone the wall because i know nothing
that you that everyone doesn't know I
don't have any inside sources anything
like that so I just read the news I
probably read more newspapers than most
normal sane people would but I don't
know but just I I think sharon has has
taken bushes measure he's decided that
that nothing he does will will cause
bush to to turn on him and that that for
a variety of reasons the domestic
political situation in the u.s. is such
that the that your own is no longer
concerned that he might face even even a
slap on the wrist in terms of his
policies so that's that's the story it's
interesting the people in the US are
terrified to cross these guys there karl
rove will call you up and scream and
obscenities at you at their tremendous
amount of of people are afraid quite a
few people outside the united states
have reached the conclusion that that
more or less that these guys can be
rolled it's kind of a very strange thing
so we've got your own not just her own
who knows that he will never be crossed
but we've got kim jong yield saying well
you know i can go and reprocess those
rods and the
Americans won't do anything and the
Iranians going ahead and saying well
while the Americans are bogged down in
Iraq they're not going to come after us
and so let's let's speed ahead with our
nuclear weapons program so it's a pretty
amazing thing all right I'm going to try
to raise way back there yeah oh sorry
sorry this was orchards being knocked
down we're in West Bank sorry in Iraq
all right oh I hadn't heard about that
one okay well I've been I've been
dodging birds so sorry all right let me
just try yeah I have to say it sounds
kind of a shore own s policy doesn't it
yes
yeah okay basically what do I think
about about terrorism and our political
system no I mean it was look I'm clearly
911 really just did a number on our on
our minds and keep on doing this and let
me recommend another book the Chris
Hedges war is a force that gives us
meaning fantastic fantastic book and he
talks about the particularly the way
that people deify their leaders in the
time of war terror almost no matter how
bad the leaders are so he talks about
how the the Argentine's rallied around
there hunted during the during the
Malvinas that the Falkland Islands war
and and that's certainly one of the
things that's happened and the the thing
that has been very hard to get across is
how little of the is how much the the
administration's foreign policy agenda
has had nothing whatsoever to do with
terrorism and also the most hate mail I
ever received the biggest piles were the
first few months after nine eleven when
I I started saying look there they are
they are exploiting this politically
they're exploiting it for unrelated
goals and people just did not want to
believe that it was very very hard we
now know that that I mean I was looking
at economic stuff we now know that the
Iraq war was something that they were
pushing for literally literally while
the towers were still burning and
without it ever finding any evidence of
a link so it distorts everything now I
thought it would fade away I thought it
would be reduced to something like the
war on drugs it would be a that the
terrorist issue would be a cut something
that we'd always be worrying about but
not not central to our politics and I
was wrong because they turned it into a
justification for another war and and so
it had managed to keep it rolling and
more people than you would believe think
that that's what what it was all about
that the war in Iraq was was about was
was in fact a big wag the dog exercise
what happens next I don't know
the at the rate things are going we may
have to go and and invade Afghanistan
all over again so it's maybe maybe a
while take one more yes okay that's a
really different one manufacturing all
right this is the place where I'm not a
predictable reliable liberal in fact i
had the American Prospect had a attack
piece on me in the mid-90s because of my
free trade arguments so let me just give
you let me give you the free trade
argument and then tell you what the
problem is right now I'm basically a
free trader pro globalization because of
the developing countries when I went to
grad school in the mid-1970s I
considered specializing in development
economics I didn't do it because it was
too depressing a field around 1975
development economics was non
development economics there were no
success stories no country had ascended
from the third world since Japan in the
1880s and the it was just you know it's
just they were there were no there was
no not much hope there's been a lot of
hope since we've had a couple of you
know full ascent from third world to
first South Korea and a lot of positive
things happening in places like China
and and ant Island and so on not not one
hundred percent positive by a means but
there's a good stories and they all
involve exports of manufactured goods to
advanced countries so you have to that
hope requires that there be a
sufficiently open world market I also
countries that just you know kept their
heads above water with that sort of
thing so we're talking about places like
Bangladesh which has avoided a
Malthusian crisis because of of labor
intensive exports all right now what do
I say about the loss of jobs in advanced
countries in return under normal
circumstances I say look that's not
actually a total number of jobs is not a
problem our ability to create jobs
depends upon our the Federal Reserve can
always cut interest rates and get the
economy moving and stuff tends to come
back and there is an issue of income
distribution there is an issue of
downward pressure on wages of
blue-collar workers and that's something
to be concerned about but it's
manageable if we have other policies
to help the income distribution which of
course we don't but we can we can
agitate for them it's very difficult
right now because with the Fed having
lowered interest rates almost as much as
it can and still no job creation you
take a look and a job lost to imports
from China or from India is a job lost
and a story what we need first office is
a real economic recovery in this country
policies that would actually address the
problem and then we can discuss this
thing more rationally and I think the
answer has to be it would just be a huge
tragedy if we closed off those
opportunities when we say my god some
some skilled jobs are moving to India
now with the service stuff that's that
one level from the firm a global point
of view that's that's a wonderful thing
this is the best we now have the first
real hope of substantial economic
development in India which is which is a
billion people the what we have to do is
find a way to sustain incomes and and in
the United States while that happens
which I think can be done with with
through taxon and and social policy last
point just to say I know easy for me to
say I mean that's this is and i'm always
on weak moral ground here because they
aren't outsourcing either college
professors or op-ed columnist yet but
that's that's still where I come down I
think I probably if I'm going to sign
books I probably have to come Prince to
a whole thang
thank you Paul Krugman's column appears
every tuesday and friday in the new york
times the great unraveling is published
by WW Norton on the web at WWE and a
life and letters contains over 1,000
letters written between 1922 and night